now let's talk about
linear programming
linear programming is very close to
linear algebra.
And it has this primary component called The
Objective function. It's just a
function
mmm, but
the point here is to either maximize the function or
minimize the function given some constraints.
So for example, let's say you want to transport.
Or let's use the shipping, you know like in
e-commerce.
and
there are some constraints that have to do
with petrol consumption.
the distance traveled the weight of the ships
the distance to
the recipients so you have these different constraints and you want to
select the parameters.
Such that you're within what we call a feasible region.
I'll show you I'll show you an example of this. I'll show
you both the mathematics and the graphical.
Explanation because graphing is
actually a big part of linear programming especially graphing
any qualities. Like I said linear algebra
is a subset of abstract algebra and abstract algebra is
a development or develops takes the
ideas from classical algebra further.
also part of classical algebra
is functions and graphing them.
In when it comes to vectors in
particular.
One technique that we will look at which has applications in.
computer vision and natural language processing by
the way a central
One of the things that we be working towards is
neural networks.
So this is kind of it's also machine learning part of this
course machine understanding machine, but neural electric
specifically not supervised and unsupervised learning.
Will be working with vectors.
So we want to apply techniques like cosine similarity, which I
said has applications both an image recognition and NLP.
But a prerequisite for understanding Vector operations
is trigonometry.
And trigonometry in turn has geometry as a prerequisite.
what I'm trying to say is this
if you've ever enrolled in a course.
Or picked up a book called linear algebra. It is
assumed that you know all four
of these at least the extent.
That would allow you to.
read that book or
complete that course successfully
what we will what I have done in this course is I
have
made supplementary material for all
four of these
So for example if we come across a word like a vector space.
The word space comes from abstract algebra, and if you do not know what that is
because you have to know what that is. If you want to make progress.
Well, then you can refer to the supplementary material.
Which talks about words like spaces?
And the Axiom is that apply to such a type
of set a space is a type of set.
And of course in order to understand the axioms then apply
through those sets. You need to know some classical algebra, but
nothing difficult. It's very straightforward. In fact, we can cover
the key Concepts here today
And then there is trigonometry trigonometry is a big deal again because
of vectors.
You know must be.
I mean, what are the applications of vectors whether it's
computer vision or even in even PC by
the way, you just vectors?
If we wanted we want to know how close they are to each
other.
So we need to understand angles.
The sign and cosine functions and for that we need to understand so
basic geometry or at least the notation geometry.
This again will be provided.
a supplementary material
So let me this is an example of Neo program. Let me give you a pictorial
representation.
and then I will take you to
markdown
because through this exercise we will get a sense of what systems
of linear equations are which is from linear algebra and
The objective function which is linear program, so, you know.
We learned two things with one example.
We have some.
function that we need to optimize to optimize means
to
At least pictorially graph it so that it satisfies
all of our four constraints. So we have these four constraints. So
yeah and this function let's particular function that we
talked about has two variables. Okay. So put differently.
It's a function of two variables two things two variables will
affect.
It's maximization or minimization. Let's because
I know hypothetical example the price
of a smartphone.
It could be a function of the size of the screen.
and
How much memory it has rather mattress memory?
Or what's another example salary?
It could be a function of
How many years of experience you have?
And how many years you've spent in in school so academic?
Experience and work experience. Okay, so
that's salary will be of than we say
that salaries a function and it's a function of two things.
Anyway here. We have a function. That is a
Whose variables are X and Y both X and Y Must Be
0.
So if we see here.
If we graph the inequality for X 0 x greater
than 0 then everything in the right quadrant.
In the first quadrant and the lower quadrant
would be highlighted.
Okay, so anything there is X anything there
is equal to or that's an inequality. I hope the pictures
are very clear, but that's an inequality and it includes zero.
It's a restrict inequality. So anything from zero or
above X will be shaded.
then we have y
must be above 0 right so Y is this vertical axis
anything about anything from 0 or above will be highlighted?
But now we have two constraints if we take these two constraints together.
then
if we just focus on these two then how do we satisfy both
of these constraints? Well,
the Shaded area must be above
The origin for why?
and
To the right of X. So in other words we will have
this region that's
basically slicing
the Shaded area
But then there's more.
Here we have this other inequality.
2x plus 5 y less than or equal to 3,500 which
gives us this inequality. This it gives us this graph.
So not only does our solution must be in the right quadrant
in the first quadrant.
And we also have this, you know vertical this diagonal line
cutting through it.
So if we have this coordinate it was also sliced it from here.
and then there's this fourth quadrant long story short we
must
perform
arithmetic operations on these two these
constraints which are inequalities
until we find the roots. And once we find the roots of
these equations, we will then have found the feasible
region of
our objective function